I'm excited here, because this gentlemen
I have been able to interact
with multiple times.
I'm always a fan of people that are
the deep practitioner and
expert in their craft.
I kind of been very narrow in my career,
whether it's been wine or marketing.
Or, now sports cards.
And this young man's expertise falls
into a place that I think is gonna make
everybody who's watching
and listening stand up.
Because we have all interacted
in the hotel ecosystem.
Also I want to give a huge shout-out
to everybody who's watching
right now on LinkedIn Live.
We're just starting that platform.
And as a matter of fact today, I made
a pretty easy structure.
Which is I want to really let Faisal speak
for five or ten minutes about
the things he cares about.
But then I really want
to help a lot of people,
because I think we're
good at like reacting.
I know your speed matches mine.
And so we'll take some questions.
We're gonna take those
questions from LinkedIn.
So if you have a question on LinkedIn,
please put in your phone number
and we will give you a call.
Faisal, I want you to introduce yourself
to the Vayner Nation.
- Yeah, Vayner Nation what's going on?
Gary thanks, always fun to
be back in New York City.
I love this place, miss it.
But Vegas is not a bad
place to live at either.
Yeah so Faisal Sublaban, present CEO
Bonotel Exclusive Travel.
We're one of the largest distributors
of luxury hotel rooms.
B2B, so we sell to say an Expedia,
and then they sell to the end consumer.
It's the easiest way for
people to understand.
- So at the luxury end, there's the room.
Then there's you in between
the room and Expedia.
- We're a middle man.
We're glorified middle men.
So what we do is we go to
a hotel and we provide,
basically, turnkey solutions to distribute
in over 73 different countries.
We work very closely as
a strategic marketing
and distribution partner.
Hence the reason we work with
the Vayner Media team as well.
- Yes.
- In order to create awareness,
and give an authentic lens
into those properties.
- But besides being an
operator like myself,
there's been a growth
within your personal brand
through content, things of that nature.
How has that been, tell me that journey?
- Yeah, I mean for me, I think you've
spoken about this before.
I had an investment group who said,
why do you need to be
on Instagram, LinkedIn.
Facebook, or any of these social platforms
creating an awareness.
I told them, whether you're in B2B, B2C,
you have to have a social media presence.
It's the way to be, it's
the way of the future.
And if not, your business
is basically irrelevant.
And so that's.
- Have you found that
producing content in that scale
and putting yourself out there has created
a scenario that has led
to business development?
- Yeah, I mean it's a top of the funnel
biz dev tool, period.
- End of story.
- Even for somebody who's
in, and you consider,
are you guys in the SAS business?
Or are you in the services business?
The broker business?
How do you even, at the highest level,
how do you position your code.
- I mean for us, there's technology
that enables distribution of inventory.
SAS is not really what I would call it.
Service, I mean it is in a lot of ways.
Service is business, cause we have people
who are traveling.
Stuff goes wrong all the time.
And so we have to distribute,
solve the problems
et cetera et cetera.
- What kind of kid were you?
- So, it's funny you say that.
So, growing up in a small
town, Lodi California.
- [Gary] Oh, wine country.
- Yeah, I think Empathy
Wines has a couple few.
- [Gary] It does, it does.
- I know, I know the Mettler family.
His mom, Brandon Mettler,
his mom was my swim mom.
- [Gary] No way.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
So definitely a connection to Lodi there.
Yeah so I grew up, my mom
came from a large family.
But we were extremely poor.
My father immigrated from the Middle East.
So he came with a 100
dollars in his pocket.
And then he was just a born entrepreneur.
So for me, constantly
exposed to entrepreneurship,
if I wanted something.
You know we were a middle class family.
My dad would say, okay come work.
So, from being a young kid I'd go
to the flea market with him.
Start slinging some car audio stereos,
or some subwoofers.
Or anything that was tied to that.
So I'd bounce around at a very young age,
six, seven, eight years-old,
interacting with adults.
So I think one of the
things that that taught me
is it gave me an exposure to
how to interact with adults.
So a lot of people have told
me I'm very mature for my age.
Even being young and in business,
my mindset thinks in a more mature
(crosstalk interrupts speech)
Even now, yeah even now.
- That's funny I had, I've
had, how old are you now?
- 38
- Makes sense, I've had that come up
in the last decade a lot more.
I finally realized it was
being in the game so early.
- Yeah, that's exactly what it is.
And you know how to interact, and then
it's emotional, it's like that EQ.
When you go, interacting with people,
reading people's behavior,
understanding it.
And then when you have
salesmanship behind it,
you're selling stuff so you have to react.
And you know, cater to those emotions.
- You know for me it was radical candor.
Because I don't like negativity.
And because I'm willing
to take on everything.
And like, want the pressure.
The thing that I had to really overcome
from my natural skills was radical candor.
I realized when I was firing
people at Wine Library
in my twenties they were shocked.
And to me I was upset at them at first,
which is a flaw.
Because I'm like, bro you suck.
You've been sucking.
But then I realized, wait a minute,
they're not self-aware that they suck.
And I've been telling
them everything's fine,
so I'm the dick.
- Yeah, no I had the same problem.
- So I really struggled with that.
- Yeah I had the same problem.
And you know there's like a
maturation process as a leader.
And even so far as a few years back,
even being a CEO, you don't
wanna tell them they suck.
Cause you're just hoping that they finally
fucking get it.
And they never do.
- You know for me it's a lot of the times,
I put them in the right position.
You know you move people around, right?
You know, like Seth used to do audio
and I was like "he sucks".
(laughing drowns out words)
(laughs)
No but like, no honestly
it's fun for my team.
Cause you guys know this,
like find me the right spots.
What really makes Vayner awesome I think,
back to Seth's point which is not true.
It's that talent was growing,
and we needed somebody strong.
And I felt like, and he
wanted a new challenge.
It was awesome.
By the way, this is like
very meta, very real now.
I'm not even sure, because I've been busy
and we haven't talked a lot lately.
I miss you a little bit, maybe we
should grab ten minutes.
How it's working or not.
But what I love is even
if it's a disaster,
and he doesn't like it.
But he likes me, and he knows
there's an opportunity here.
If he like did this, and
he came to me tomorrow,
and was like "Hey, I want
to do something else".
Or be back on team
Gary, or go to whatever.
We would work on it and
try to figure it out.
What's really cool is eight years later,
he'd be like you know what that was good.
Because I learned this during that time.
There's things inherently
that he's learning there.
Right, I can see by your body language.
So, I think it's optimistic management.
If you can afford it, you may end up
with somebody who's a
much better executive
because they're learning context in
all those different things.
So I think it's offense.
- [Faisal] Well that's
it, people don't wanna.
- It's easy to fire.
- Yeah, easy to fire.
But I think , a lot of
- [Gary] It's easy for somebody to quit.
- A lot of people are afraid
to roll up their sleeves
and actually let themselves be vulnerable
in those situations.
And actually look at it as hey,
maybe I'm gonna learn something
I didn't learn before.
That will be valuable
somewhere down the road.
- What's the biggest thing you feel like
you want to evolve next?
Like what's on your mind right now,
as an entrepreneur, as a
leader, as an executive?
That you're like, you know
what over the next decade
I would like to be better at?
- Well I think when you look at,
within the travel hospitality space.
I just think it's ripe for
some sort of disruption.
I think you have these influencers
who are out posting about properties,
and travel, where most
of them can't afford it.
No knock on those that can.
- So you are saying, we know this.
Half the people watching right now,
are aspiring to be a travel influencer.
Because everybody wants to travel.
And like, who wouldn't want to go to Maui
and stay in a five-star place.
And just post a photo, and call it a day.
Are you saying that it's
that they themselves cannot?
Or their audience doesn't
have a high percentage
of people who can.
- I think it's actually both.
There's a few that can, obviously.
That have done a great job
monetizing their brand.
- And you're not saying
that, to your point,
that you're razzing anyone.
You're saying that that may not be a good
business arbitrage for that business.
Because you're trying to get awareness.
But if you're getting
awareness for something
one can't afford
- [Faisal] That doesn't covert
its not the right type of clientele.
And so I think, you know one of the things
that I've been focused on,
is making luxury attainable.
And so when you look at that,
everybody loses context
around what does that mean.
So you have people in which,
some people a four-star hotel is luxury.
Then to other people it
has to be a five-star hotel
in order for them to feel luxury.
And every person is different.
It's all around context.
- To this day, the most luxury thing
that I've every felt was the Holiday Inn
in Orlando, Florida.
When I was ten years
old, because we'd never
spent a dollar on anything.
And going on that vacation, we stayed
in the fucking Holiday Inn.
And I remember thinking how fancy it was.
And like to this day, and
I've stayed in some places
cause of my lifestyle.
And when you travel and you speak,
they put you up in rooms.
You know it's funny,
it's funny what people
spend money on.
I will right now, like
this week I'm gonna spend
thousands of dollars buying custom jerseys
of random Jets players who
will barely play this year.
But, with hotel rooms I'm
a very give me the bed,
I'm shower pressure and wifi.
- [Faisal] Yeah yeah, wifi is good.
Dirty room, I'm fine cause I'm dirty.
(Faisal laughs)
It's just the truth,
I'm telling the truth.
It doesn't really
register, like cockroach.
(mumbles)
But if the wifi, or if
the shower pressure.
With your influence
now in the hotel space,
can we start getting more data around?
Can we create a standardization
around shower pressure.
And then they can show
me on the hotel room.
That's my fucking thing
Rob, that's what I can fix.
- You know who actually tests that?
You know who tests that, Four Seasons.
So I went to their headquarters.
They literally have all the pipes there.
So they test how loud it is,
so that the room next to it.
Because nobody wants to
hear water rushing through.
- I do, that's how I sleep actually.
I sleep with a sound machine on.
And if I could hear the
shower in the other room,
I could pump.
But I know most people don't.
Shower pressure.
- [Faisal] And then they test
the pressure, they test the pressure.
They do, they test the
pressure, they do it.
But it is a huge thing.
I would agree with you.
- I also wanna have hotel rooms now
that don't have the bar in the room.
Sometimes I travel in third, you know,
kind of smaller cities.
And it's one of those hotels where
all the food's downstairs.
I get pumped, because then
I don't eat dumb shit.
Cause I eat dumb shit when they like,
- Oh and you have like the
gummy bears sitting there.
And it's like the shit.
- They're never fucking good.
Every time I'm like,
one of the weird things
about eating gummy bears is the bet
you have to make with yourself.
If they're actually soft.
(Faisal laughs)
- It's true, cause if they're stale,
if they're stale you're
like this is the worst
unhealthy decision I've made.
- Worst decision ever.
- I knew I should have
went with the apples.
- And you paid like 42 dollars for it.
- [Faisal] Exactly.
- And they fucking suck.
- You leave them behind,
but then you take them
cause you feel guilty.
- I think it's one of the great decisions
that are not talked about enough.
Which is the decision to buy gummy bears,
predicated on not really knowing
if they're soft enough.
And most people, is anybody here
a hard gummy bear eater?
- No, no I think that's disgusting.
- You are Drela?
You like them hard versus soft?
- I'm gonna send you all
the shitty gummy bears.
(laughs)
Chewy is soft, you gotta like.
- You get the harder ones but sometimes
they come, if they're stale they're hard.
I need them out of the fucking machine.
Actually here's a good business idea.
I think gummy bears should do a pop up,
like a pop up truck where
they're making them on the spot.
I'd fucking wait in line for that shit.
- Ah man for sure.
Hot, gummy, soft.
- Soft as fuck.
I'm a soft as fuck gummy bear person.
Let's do phone calls right off.
Cause we're clearly veering here.
- [Faisal] We've deviated.
- If you're watching LinkedIn, put your
phone number in if you have a question
for Faisal and I.
Anything about the hospitality space,
entrepreneurship, the flip life.
Cause I guess we both live that.
Who's this?
- [Man] This is Alex.
- Alex.
(phone rings)
Fucking gummy bears.
- [Alex] Hello, this is Alex.
- Alex, it's Gary Vaynerchuck.
- [Faisal] How's it going, Alex?
- [Alex] Gary, oh my God, how are you?
- Please say hello to Faisal.
- [Alex] Hey, how are you?
- God how are you?
- [Alex] I'm really good.
- [Gary] What can we
answer for you, brother?
- [Alex] Um, so, wow this is crazy.
(Gary and Faisal laugh)
So I work in hospitality.
I'm in medicine and I do house calls
to all the hotels in Los Angeles
(sound quality makes dialog hard to hear)
- Interesting.
- [Alex] And I'm leaving
traditional medicine to do that.
It really kind of made me
wonder about the concept
of hospitality as a whole in traditional
business and kind of.
Cause in hospitality it's really about
treating people with the
highest level of service
that you can.
And I feel like that's sort of missing
in traditional business.
And I just kind of wondered
what your thoughts on that were?
- Yeah, I mean for me personally,
I think you're right.
But I think that you're
seeing worlds colliding
within all different industries.
Around creating an
experience that's centered
around hospitality.
You have fitness brands,
you have hotel brands
coming into fitness.
Fitness brands going into hotels.
If you look at hotels
and concierge doctors,
or even dentists.
You know I was sitting with my wife.
She's telling me there are offices where
it's kind of a spa.
So everyone traditionally
hates going to the dentist.
You go in there and
you can get a pedicure.
While you're getting your
teeth drilled on, I guess.
What I think though for
somebody like yourself,
you know it is all about
the guest experience.
And taking care of people in whatever
industry that you're in.
And if you're focused on your customer,
at the end of the day.
And doing everything to ensure
that they are taken care of.
Now you're creating that
unique hospitable experience
that you build a real business around.
- I wrote a book called
"The Thank You Economy"
in 2011 that has undertones
of your questions brother.
I think that businesses,
if everybody thought
that they were in the
hospitality business,
and then they sold concrete.
And then they sold wine.
And then they sold salads.
And then they made sneakers.
I actually think it's one of the best
arbitrages to building a brand.
- [Faisal] For sure.
- I mean everybody who
is watching right now
who is an influencer,
if they just randomly DM
25 followers right now.
And ask for their address,
and then sent a wink.
And said it's a surprise.
And sent them all some sort of basket,
with a handwritten note.
That would be better for
their influencer business.
But people don't think that way.
- [Alex] I agree, it's
kind of what's helped me
become successful in a
short period of time.
Cause you know, when you go to the doctor
or to the hospital, you know.
You're just kind of there to figure out
what's wrong and get a
prescription, or whatever.
But when you really really
have the hospitality mindset,
of trying to take care of people.
And do everything you can to make it
more of an experience, than just the quick
in and out, am I getting what I need.
- It's empathy as well.
(all talk at the same time)
Brother it's super smart.
I think you should write
more LinkedIn posts
about your thoughts on this.
Cause it could lead to
other opportunities.
Keep that in mind.
- [Alex] I agree, thanks.
- You got it brother.
Thanks for giving a call.
You know look, I think it's a
really interesting question.
When I think about you,
and what I know about you.
I think about myself.
It goes into a very interesting thing
(speaks too fast)
I think we were born entrepreneurs,
and we were trained entrepreneurs.
And the reality is, me
being in the wine business.
You being in the hotel business.
Me being in marketing, you know.
It really was agnostic,
it was serendipitous.
- It doesn't matter, I mean I was in
finance mortgages before.
It doesn't matter.
- That's right, and I think if I run it,
if we run into each other
in an airport in nine years.
Cause serendipitously we got busy
and weren't communicating.
And you're like, yo I've got a huge,
you know like, beef jerky business.
In my mind I'd be like yep.
And I kind of, the way I think about
entrepreneurship, is how I think
about hospitality.
Just cause you're in the hotel business,
or things of that nature.
Hospitality is an oxygen.
It's a mindset, it's a culture.
And it can be deployed against everything.
- Yeah, and people actually
are attracted to it.
They gravitate towards it.
They aspire to have it.
- [Gary] You bring in value.
- Value, at the end of
the day it's all it is.
- Alec?
- [Faisal] Alec.
- You're really creative
around here, Ronald.
Alex, Alec.
(phone rings)
- [Faisal] Alec, Alec.
- Alec's gonna miss his big chance.
(voicemail message)
- [Voicemail Automated Voice]
At the tone, please record
your message, when you finish recording
you may hang up, or press
one for more options.
(beep)
Alec Brown, this is Gary Vaynerchuck.
You fucked up, you did
not answer the phone call.
And you will be calling back
like everyone else who
fucks up on this show.
But we will not be answering it,
because everything in
life is about timing.
I wish you great health and happiness.
- [Faisal] Love ya.
(laughs)
- Let's go to the next one.
By the way, I think a lot about
what just happened too.
Like, one of the great things
about entrepreneurship is...
People always ask me what
mistakes have you made.
And I always talk about my Uber past.
- [Faisal] Not answering the phone.
- But you know what's funny?
I know the biggest mistake I ever made
was canceling a meeting
I was about to have.
That would have been the domino piece
to make everything work, you know.
- We've all done that.
And when you go, you just
don't put it together.
- I think about it all the time.
And I've canceled some pretty
fancy fucking meetings,
but I also think it's the
unfancy ones that you just know.
Patrick.
- [Patrick] It's Patrick.
- Patrick, it's Gary Vaynerchuck
and you're on with Faisal.
How are you?
- [Patrick] Doing good guys,
how are you guys doing?
- [Faisal] Great, great thank you.
- [Patrick] All right, so the question is
I have two businesses.
One where I do graphic media, photography,
videography,
(speaks too fast)
Local businesses, and I also do printing.
The biggest problem that I have
is bridging that gap between basically
working on my own, working for myself
and then finally starting to hire
an executive assistant, printing manager.
Somebody.
What kind of formula would you consider,
or even like think about.
What is your foundation
in which you feel like
you need to have prior to getting that
first person to help you off load
a lot of the work to
continue progressing forward.
- So, before I'm gonna
let Faisal go first.
But I was asking Rog of something
I might have missed one point.
You're telling me the challenge at hand
is actually just scaling your business?
Like literally hiring and
letting go of certain things.
And understanding how to manage that,
and afford it.
And just the whole strategy of scaling?
- [Patrick] Yeah, essentially that.
The biggest thing is like
getting that one person
to come on, and getting
that one person to basic.
Cause I know the next step is to basically
get additional people in to help me
off load the work that I currently have.
To continue growing.
But what are the basic things
that you would require before getting
that first person to come on.
- Yeah, first and foremost,
you have to be able to
within two minutes or less,
articulate your vision.
Like you're explaining it to your grandma.
That's first and foremost.
You have to have what are you doing.
Or what you think you're doing.
That can change and iterate a thousand
different times along the way.
I think it's incredible reckless to bring
somebody in without any sort of path
or vision for what you're trying to build.
To be honest with you,
what's in it for them?
At the end of the day.
The next thing is.
- I will add one point to that.
I think that was big business talk,
from like a little bit of a startup,
and a bigger thing.
To answer, to add to that.
Cause I think that's
right, but at his scale
what's in it for the other person
is whatever they're getting paid.
- Yeah, yeah but I mean
it's also come with me.
I'm starting it up, like
they've gotta be excited
to come in at a one person job.
- [Gary] I respect that too.
- [Patrick] I definitely
have revenue, I have profit,
things like that.
The biggest things that
I would say that I have,
the biggest concern, is
you know I don't have
a storefront just yet, things like that.
We would be working satellite together
for a while until I get to that next step.
- That's actually more
fun most of the time.
- Why do you have to work satellite?
- [Patrick] Because
everything that I basically do
is out of my own home right now.
- Okay, and what do you want
the first employee to do?
- [Patrick] The first
employee I would have to say
would be client management.
While I continue to sell.
- Makes sense.
- Yeah, makes perfect sense.
- So, what's Stopping you from hiring
her or him now?
- [Patrick] Uh, biggest
thing is honestly making sure
that I have enough profit margin
to consistently pay one person.
To take care of my current clients,
so I can go ahead and keep selling.
- Makes sense, makes sense.
Good answer.
- [Patrick] So what's your
consideration of percentage?
Or anything like that,
where would you get,
- There's no right answer, there's only
your actual path.
You know, would I would say by that is
do you have a sense of how
much that person costs?
Do you have that much profit
in the last 12 months?
And what are you doing with your money
that you're taking out of the business,
if you are.
So let's go through that.
- [Faisal] Are you drawing a salary?
Is this business paying you anything?
- [Patrick] Yeah, so
basically it's just paying
my very minimal bills.
That's basically what it's paying.
- And this is all you do right?
This is your life?
- [Patrick] 100%, yeah I
quit my job six months ago.
This all I do.
- Do you have any debt?
- [Patrick] No.
- So you're debt free human.
- [Patrick] Yes.
- And right now you're
at exactly bare minimum,
I'm gonna make this up without prying.
The business does 64000
in top line revenue.
And it makes you 40000 profit,
cause there is nothing you're selling.
It's just your time.
And you live exactly 40000
dollar a year lifestyle.
- [Patrick] Pretty close.
- Okay, so there's a couple things.
One, I want to know what's
in that 40000 right.
One of the things, when my
friends say those things to me.
And they let me look
at every single thing.
Or somebody that really wants my help
and shows me everything.
Inevitably everyone's
got a little more kush
than they realize because somehow
people think certain things are required.
And they're not.
And you know, literally.
I kind of lived this
lifestyle for a big part
of my twenties, the only expense I had
was car, gas, food, and roof.
I literally didn't buy, literally
(speaks too fast)
From the store was my outfits.
And literally there was no
entertainment cost involved.
And that's why I was able to hire people,
because I was able to
live on $37000 a year.
I think you've got a decision to make.
One, go super hard and
create that growth yourself.
And wait another year or two.
You could take on debt.
You could, I hate it.
I hate it.
But, what I really am excited about,
just kind of even going on vibes.
Is if if you do hire that person,
to do a lot of the defense shit.
It lets you go on the offense
and your growth accelerates even greater
than your cost, do you see what I mean?
- [Patrick] Exactly.
- I mean the first place you have to look
is your lifestyle costs, right?
And is there anything you
can do to go more humble?
If you really put your
business ahead of yourself.
I've put my businesses ahead of myself.
Everyday of my life and my career,
which is why I've built huge businesses.
Most people think they build businesses
so they can buy shit from the businesses.
And they take from the business.
I feed the business.
- [Patrick] Yes.
- And it sounds like
you're going that path.
Now the question becomes,
how much shittier
can your lifestyle be?
If you want to get there faster?
- It's not forever, but
you gotta buckle down
if you want to actually come out.
- [Gary] Or you wait, right Faisal?
- I actually, I have a thought to wear.
If you have the ability to hire somebody,
and you have the margins that are there.
Or at least like close to.
I had one investor when
when one of my companies
that I had started,
Lohoya Wealth Management.
In San Diego, it was a
mortgage finance company.
And we were about to take on a lease
that was a little bit pricey.
But in order to be in the area,
to attract the clients we had to do it.
You know what she told me, she said
sometimes being stretched
and putting your ass
and back against the
wall, is the best thing
to motivate you to excel even further.
And she was right, like I
took on a little bit more
than I could chew in order
to build the business.
And it forced you, because
everyday you're more hungry.
Because you're scared of not
being able to pay that person.
- Patrick, there's no math equation.
People do it, this is why people think
you go to school for business.
And they say the proper thing is 32.3%
of your fucking, that's fine.
That's not real life, that's like thesis.
Right?
The answer to your
question is very simple.
You're at the crossroads.
Either, you take on debt
or you raise capital.
That gives you money to be able to hire
Susan or Johnathan.
Or you wait another year,
and go slower, save even more.
Create more margin, bleed a little more.
To be able to feel
comfortable that you'll be,
six months runway on a
salary that you can pay.
And then you go on the
offense to close that gap.
Does that make sense?
- [Patrick] Absolutely.
- It's as simple as that.
- [Faisal] And you can do it.
- And by the way, there is
no right way of those two.
Those are the alternatives.
The only other alternative
is if your overhead
of your lifestyle is far
greater than barebone.
And you cut into that, right?
That's it, those are the three moves.
There's three moves in this scenario.
- Grow it, grow the
business a little bit more.
Save some cash, you do
exactly the other two things.
That's it.
- By the way, and this is where it gets,
there's never that's it.
You could borrow 50000
bucks from your uncle.
You could, ya could.
- [Patrick] Yeah.
- You could sell all the fucking shit
in your home on Facebook
Marketplace and Ebay
and make 5000 extra a month on the side.
You could, I mean there's shit to be done.
- There's a sacrifice either way.
Like you just gotta pick
which one you wanna go with.
And then double down and just go with it.
- [Patrick] To be honest I
think I'm super offensive.
And so because I'm super
offensive I'm probably
just gonna dive into it
and just use the uncle
with $50000 as a okay now my
ass is really in the fire.
Maybe this is a good time to borrow.
So I think I'm gonna go with option A,
just throw it down and start selling more.
And allow a person to play
defense on the backend.
And then if I really need it,
I'll borrow.
- [Faisal] Bet on yourself.
Bet on yourself.
- Awesome, good luck brother.
- [Faisal] See ya.
- [Patrick] Thank you brother.
- Good, that was good for the audience.
Like that's the process.
Let's see one more and
then we'll get out of here.
Anything you want to talk about
before we leave, that we didn't get to?
- Yeah I mean, a lot of interesting things
coming from the content
side within our business.
And what we're looking to do.
Started our podcast, "Business Class".
- [Gary] Give it a shout out.
So what is it?
- "Business Class", it's on.
- [Gary] So if you search it on,
- On the podcasts you'll
see "Business Class".
- [Gary] What do people expect from that?
- So it's actually really interesting,
it's not just travel related.
We do talk about travel
with almost every guest.
Just to get their unique insights
of where they've been.
But really it's different entrepreneurs
that have come from all walks of life.
And just done some interesting things.
- How many episodes have you done?
- So we've shot now 12.
We've launched seven of them.
- Who's been the best guest?
I'm putting you directly on the spot,
this will hurt 11 other human's feelings.
And make one, yeah exactly this is life.
- I mean I had to, so one guy I vibed with
completely well, Michael
Trenell who you had on here.
He's awesome,
- I like wanna be friends with him.
- Yeah no he's a dope dude.
The other one who's super interesting,
another buddy of mine, is Matt Goss.
So that one hasn't aired
yet, he was an interesting.
He's an artist, they're always interesting
and creative.
- Which one was the
better show of the two?
- I mean like vibing, I think it's...
- Well the vibing is only one variable.
Best net show.
- Uh, Trenell.
- And there's aired?
- Yeah, it's aired, it's live.
You can swipe up, I'll
put it on stories later.
@TheHotelBoss on IG.
@TheHotelBoss.
(Gary mumbles in background)
Yeah exactly, boom boom boom.
- [Automated Voice] The
number you have dialed
is not in service.
- [Faisal] You got trolled.
- Can we clip that for TED talk?
(Faisal laughs)
See your fucking fan.
Talk.
- I do have a funny baseball cards story.
So I remember I was working
at the Napa flea market
for my dad, I was eight years old.
And I had a Bo Jackson rookie card.
(Gary speaks in background)
Yeah.
- [Gary] Football, A Topps?
- Football, the A Topps.
So we're going in, working through there.
Go to try and buy some cards
from the local card
dealers at the flea market.
Well the guy took advantage of me,
traded like a Michael Jordan card,
and here which were not as valuable.
Yeah, whatever.
And I was like a young kid that got
pushed over by an adult.
And took it.
So I went back,
- [Gary] I love getting
those kind of kids.
- Then afterwards,
(laughs)
- Hey kid, come over here it's Gary Vee.
I love you, here's a deal.
Rip off.
- He taught me a lesson, so I was like
"this guy ripped me off dad".
So he goes, lets go talk to him.
So he had him go card
by card and look it up,
and the value of it.
So it was not in my favor.
You know, I thought, oh
my dads gonna make him
give it to me back.
And basically my dad said, "now you know,
"control and manage your assets".
And take care of them,
for the rest of your life.
He let me walk away with
the shit end of the stick.
- What a great job by your dad.
Unlike 98% of parents
now that want to fight
on behalf of the kid.
- [Faisal] Oh, yeah yeah.
- Deems them non-usable.
(Faisal laughs)
- [Faisal] It's true.
- It's fucking true.
- Its true.
- [Gary] Let your kids lose.
- Yeah exactly, it's okay I'm still here.
I'm alive.
- [Alex] Hello, this is Alex.
- Alex?
Alex, what's up man,
it's Gary Vee and Faisal.
How are you?
- [Alex] Good, how are you guys?
- We're doing well, what's your question?
- [Alex] All right, I'm
trying to like start
a podcast business on like talking about
my community, and the local businesses.
- Okay.
- [Alex] And I'm just
wondering if that's possible?
- It is, you live in America?
- [Alex] I live in
(audio quality drowning speech)
Washington, small little town.
- It's possible.
- [Alex] Okay, so should
I just start with like
- Yep.
- [Alex] The small, or like
how should I go about it?
- Yes, yes.
- Small, people around you, your network.
Start building it from there.
- Alex, let me ask a question.
Are you looking for
affirmation, help me help you.
Are you asking if it's a good idea?
Tell me what you're doing here right now.
- [Alex] I'm just trying to figure out
if it's a good idea.
- The answer is yeah, how old are you?
- [Alex] I'm 25.
- Awesome, and you're doing this
because you want to be an entrepreneur.
And you've heard me or others,
talk about podcasts slash local.
And you're putting the pieces together,
and you're like you can see a world
where you're interviewing
local business or people.
Like, you feel good about that?
- [Alex] Yeah, I think
that would be great.
To get the local businesses
that we have out there.
- Good, and is your concern
that it's too narrow?
And you might not get enough ad revenue,
and then thus at some point will be.
Yeah, so let me give you the answer.
The answer is yes.
Now that I've asked those questions.
Here's why, one, you need the experience.
And thinking about it is
never better than doing it.
Okay?
- [Alex] Yeah, totally.
- That's number one.
Number two, if you do it well,
even though your podcast
might not be that monetizable.
Though the local chamber of commerce,
and 1500 bucks, and 2500 bucks from all
the local businesses could add up
to a nice little 50 to 100 thousand dollar
revenue business.
What may more likely happen,
is that you do it well
and you start a business
because all the local businesses
ask you to do their podcast.
And now you build a 500
thousand dollar business
being a service provider.
You see what I mean?
Action leads to opportunity.
- [Alex] That's what I'm thinking about.
And I wanna like video it too,
so I have video for my Instagram.
- I understand, I understand.
- He also builds a network.
He builds a network of
people that could lead.
I mean what I always think,
there's a network to where.
If you have positive intent.
Of course you personally are trying
to build your podcast.
But if you're digging deep into
these entrepreneurs, and providing value
and exposure for them.
Whether they're millionaires or just
starting their businesses.
They're going to feel this little inkling
of I owe this kid something.
And then all of a sudden, there may be
the opportunity and you know them.
And have built a rapport with them,
and they trust you.
Or they may be your first
investor to the business
that you come up with as well.
- Alex, are you dating or married?
- [ Alex] Yeah, I'm married right now.
- Okay, awesome.
That eliminates the other ROY from this.
To paint a fun picture of actual life,
where you could've met your wife.
Nonetheless, stick with me here.
Let me tell you why I was
gonna go down that path,
and I asked you that question.
- [Alex] Uh-huh.
- Doing always beats thinking.
- [Alex] Yeah, totally.
- The end.
Our phone call was almost, you know,
luckily I was in the mood.
But there was a part of me that was
halfway home to just hanging up on you.
Because, in a good way.
Just being, yes, and that's it.
To make a point for the
audience, and to you.
We're sticking out and
being a little calmer today.
But like, it's yes, do it bro.
Just do it.
I don't understand, you're
in fucking Nike country.
Just do it, you're in
the pacific North West.
You guys understand that fucking motto.
Just fucking make.
Like, all this overthinking.
I'm just so tired of
everybody overthinking.
Whether it was the best use of you time,
or not, actually doing it is better.
People spend so much time debating,
that even if they would
have done the wrong thing.
They still had more time on their hand.
I like doing, and finding out I'm wrong,
and still saving time.
Everyone still values their time,
or they're so insecure
about people judging
their decision that
they don't fucking make.
- By not doing the only
thing you're gonna have
is regret that you didn't.
And when you start doing it,
and you get positive feedback.
You're gonna be like shit,
I should have done this a
year ago when I dialed in.
- And when you do it and
you fucking suck at it,
you've now realized you've
built on your self awareness.
You're like, I'm not a
fucking podcaster, next.
- [Alex] Yeah, exactly.
And that's why I started to do more
like edits on my Instagram.
And like I started doing the
(audio quality making dialog hard to hear)
Doing edits on those so
I can practice on that.
And just really just trying
to get more out there.
And build something that like my community
doesn't have like
(audio quality making dialog hard to hear)
They don't have.
- Make make make, I love it brother.
Good luck, go make.
- [Alex] Thanks Gary.
- Thanks for being on the show brother.
- [Faisal] Thank you, good times.
- You've helped some
entrepreneurs locally,
and out there.
- [Faisal] Always good.
- You get to ask a question of the day,
any question you want.
- All right, seeing that I work
in the travel industry.
If you could travel to one place
for the rest of your
life where would you go?
- MetLife Stadium.
(everyone laughs)
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
Awesome brother.